was there ever
a cameo from somebody a guest appearance
on nitro circus
uh and the person was a bigger [ __ ]
than i was
when i was on nitro circus
you know what's interesting i'm gonna go
with no
i'm gonna go wait what happened really
interesting
you would volunteer you were like i'm in
you just didn't wanna so nitro circus
it's all about like you actually have to
do the stun
whereas i feel jackass is just hit go
fall off a cliff or jump obviously you
know what i mean like down the hill
gravity bulls
like once you say go you're in well you
had control of the
the throttle right and you just wouldn't
go fast enough to make it worthwhile but
you don't have control of a bull
or a dynamite or bees or guns and i
realized that that's what your guys
stick was that
you just you committed to doing
something and then you didn't want to
be the one that had to hurt yourself i
do i think that you've just about nailed
it and that's a problem
like across the board when you when you
have to do something it's so much easier
to like close your eyes and stay still
and wait for something awful to happen
then i disagree
knoxville goes bulls are a win-win i'm
like no
if it doesn't hit you the footage is
unusable and if it hits you you get hit
by a bull
how is this a win-win situation because
when you get hit in the nuts you want
your eyes closed and i'm like there's no
[ __ ] way i'm closing my eyes waiting
for that i have to have my eyes closed
why because otherwise i'll flinch
yeah dude